bonsoir anthony bonsoir ans bientôt
trois mois de guerre volodymyr zelensky
le président ukrainien est devenu une
figure de la résistance ukrainienne sa
popularité a donné lieu à des objets
dérivés à son effigie
dernier exemple entendre c'est ce
qu'indique en tout cas plusieurs
publications sur les réseaux sociaux ce
timbre le voici un timbre évidemment en
couleur or et bleu celle du drapeau
ukrainien orné vous le voyez du visage
de chef de l'état est bien ce timbre
existe bel et bien cette information
elle a suscité la sympathie de certains
internautes comme celle ci qui salue
l'initiative d'autres au contraire la
jugent plutôt malvenue et pousse la
comparaison avec ce qu'avait fait adolf
hitler en son temps on sait que la
dénazification
de l'ukraine est un laïc motif de
vladimir poutine pour justifier sa
guerre et quelle est l'origine de ce
timbre on va le regarder à nouveau pour
essayer de trouver un indice regardez
ici plus précisément deux mots qui
signifie poste polonaise sauf qu'il ne
faut pas toujours se fier aux apparences
et contrairement à ce qu on pourrait
donc penser est ce qu on peut aussi lire
sur différentes publications sur les
réseaux sociaux ce timbre n'a pas été
initiée par la poste polonaise
d'ailleurs la confirmation elle nous est
donnée par l'un des porte parole de sept
postes polonaise sur son compte twitter
qui nous parle d'un timbre créés à
l'aide d'un service qui permet de
choisir son visuel c'est vrai que c'est
le cas dans plusieurs pays notamment la
france 2001 fox finalement puisqu'il ya
bien un timbre à l'effigié vous l'aurez
compris de volodymyr zelensky mais elle
n'est même pas de la poste polonaise on
garde ça dans un coin de nos têtes et on
va penser recherche inversée la fameuse
si l'on utilise la photo ça nous ramène
par exemple à cet article en ukrainien
ou assez d'articles en anglais quand on
lit un petit peu plus on retrouve un mot
que l'on voit ici que je vais entouré
lukas vantage qui est conseiller
municipal à la mairie de cracovie en
pologne donc on n'est pas loin on va
revenir sur ce nom plus précisément
retrouver sa page facebook et en jetant
un coup d'oeil à son compte facebook on
retrouve effectivement plusieurs
publications notamment depuis 10 mai il
affirme être à l'origine de ce timbre on
clique sur photos et on les retrouve
dans différents endroits par exemple ici
on encore on le voit c'est lui à droite
avec cette planche de timbres alors le
visuel on le doit à un artiste de rue
qui se retrouvent sur d'ailleurs ce
visuel sur différents murs de la ville
de cracovie mais alors pourquoi en faire
un timbre pourquoi cette démarche est
bien la rédaction des observateurs de
france 24 a conseillé à interviewer ce
conseiller municipal il répondait aux
questions d'alexandre capron
web to print
en
disant
alors pas sûr qu'il ait de réponse de
l'ambassadeur de russie à varsovie on
sait cette carte postale qui
l'envoyaient avec le timbre donc en
question en tout cas sa démarche elle a
rencontré un franc succès puisque sur
les près de 900 timbre et qu'il a un
prix mais ils se sont vendus comme des
petits pains en moins de six heures
l'argent récolté sera reversé à l'armée
ukrainienne mais il nous a confié bien
qu'il n'irait pas plus loin tout
simplement parce que ça lui revenait
beaucoup trop cher et vous l'avez
entendu au début de son intervention il
évoque le mot ce grâce aux navires
russes il y à un mois qui a coulé en mer
noire alors une attaque honte s'est
revendiquée par les ukrainiens mais
démentie par les russes souvenez vous à
l'époque aussi il était question d'un
timbre ils avaient été édités avant le
naufrage du navire un franc succès là
aussi l'image que l'on doit un
dessinateur de lviv un boris gros on le
voit un soldat ukrainiens face aux
mauves qui va avec et oui c'est bien ça
un doigt d'honneur un message clair
comme de l'eau de roche merci beaucoup
anthony à saint-léger vous restez avec
nous on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau journal dans ce
paris direct
[Musique]